yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing create a who is that it doesn't
have any sort of information in there
and it's an extremely weird account
anyway so let's see how I didn't want to
play the French oh if I'm of course
weather okay let's see yeah this is the
way I usually played the French back
when I was a regular French player so
you could see what happens
I think 93 or castles is what they
usually do
yeah okay need to find his opening book
and have a look or what is the point
this is the start of the opening theory
not the end
he's taking taking his time
it's a totally normal theoretical
position Bishop g5 you can go Bishop e7
this that's the stuff with night b5 but
I still think that should be 7 is
correct would seem James takes Knight B
5 a 6 doesn't really do much I have T 6
covered at the mode
wonder I wonder what his plan is yeah I
mean it's been a while since I played
this opening with Black Knight H for
sometimes is interesting for black
trying to trade those nights and then
get a better pressure against the d4
pawn you want to know what is weird
about this account yeah yeah I can show
you
so here's the account we have some funky
ratings here bullet rating is 1400 was
1900 at one point which is still pretty
bad and this is from 1998
so this account is almost twenty years
old but it's also completely terrible
but know what here just recently 2500 in
five minutes one minute just 1700
oh my goodness and now I can take d4
yeah so he has calculated that 90 X 9
takes Knight takes Queen g4 is an
interesting way to play okay so I go
here now probably 95 esta the point so
he gets the Knight to d6 after all if I
take D for now yes this the check on d6
so I will castle so okay now I cannot
take on d4 of course can I somehow
somehow trade stuff yeah night before
maybe we'll take a seven at the end hmm
doesn't work
once the knight is only six it's very
difficult to get rid of it really is
night before yeah he will take c8 and
take a seven I guess and it still looks
right somehow
what does he just play Knight is no 96 I
take c1 okay that doesn't work so this
one and now 97 cold blooded okay ain't
no egos 2d6 okay so so rooks e7 what's
the deal there's some tactic don't quite
know Queen b3 this Bishop h7 in this
position so I cover f7 you should be one
hmm that looks like a decent move cover
stuff okay well that we can spit sex but
we can't be 6f for like some Queen b3
business of course I need to try to
trade this thing maybe I can put it to
d8 yeah b6 97 or so I mean it looks
pretty bad but
threatening checkmate okay
I wonder if he actually finishes as
speeds up at one point we have seen
those kind of things before so Queen
wants to go to age six or probably
something like Queen age six Queen f8a
Queen trade would be fine
so if here and then Bishop a6 and I
cannot take this is why the queen is on
f4 this is why the queen is on f4 like I
don't ever I cannot take okay so maybe I
can do this Knight no Knight a5 doesn't
lead anywhere anyway 95c for something
yeah the move h5
okay it's not not the kind of move here
love to blame I cannot take Age 4
because f7 is hanging so high morning
all very nicely played
so f5 f5 takes Queen takes there's
probably Queen age six which is all very
good all very nice ok so show me how
exactly you you play this now he would
probably take Queen takes and then some
Queen age six or something Queen age six
I mean we already know that it's going
to play this perfectly yes now ya know
what surprise coming here you can also
just promote and play Queen c7 I'm
surprised that Jan that there wasn't a
mate that looked it looked like that
could be a maid and Queen e5 is going to
finish me off now it's much better than
rating it's too bad this position is too
bad unfortunately there's probably a
fourth checkmate otherwise I would win
on time against the cheetah I really
don't know why people can't waste the
that times with this stuff
just need a queen trade to win this on
time check check check check okay
white for if it's time yeah okay so if
you use an engine just play quicker just
play quicker I mean what do people do
with their lives this is so utterly
ridiculous I mean this is the most
obvious engine cheating ever I mean
they'll Google account
yeah what what's going on there this is
a 20 year old account with crap ratings
and then all of a sudden you decide
let's use an engine yeah let's let's
kick people's but in the five minute
pool I mean this is sick and every guy
with the brain will recognize that this
is cheating what is this I mean okay I
will record it he will get banned that's
the story I don't understand what people
do just just try to play better
I mean and do something serious yeah
what what is the deal okay so we had
this and I mean okay we can I don't know
what engine this guy was using I mean
stockfish is a good bet because it's
free and we'll see ya there should be
three a stock Fischer smooth I played
here takes takes 95 so a looksie one I
don't know whatever I drop c1 he did
play I played here he takes takes g3 you
know 96 but they are similar
similarly evaluated g3 back there should
be 193 now Queens e3 establishes Fame
initially what did he play queen - III
and the nether was nicely played I mean
this is instructive really but it is it
is just yeah g4i yeah you have to see
that I mean it's it's now the my my
computer might be weaker than his or he
might choose second second line was but
this is a I'm just getting my butt
handed to me by someone was her highest
rating is some yeah yeah this is this is
all computer and quick Queen Queen f3 is
also something that you have to see all
that that there is no perpetual yeah
yeah anyway so anyway I report them and
this is such-and-such that's an easy ban
yeah so thanks for watching now some
people think I should pose the cheetah
games yes one